one who lost person got triggered this
that the other some person was like
gaslighting the other so a lot of people
say that you know Hafiz you got
triggered uh in this situation and then
maybe you were maybe condescending to
pearls these are what people are saying
okay but I also know that you're a very
um
emotional guy like you wear your heart
on your sleeve uh you're you're
passionate so I I feel like some people
don't maybe not know that about you even
like behind the scenes you're like yo
what up bro like that's you yeah so
you're having passion is a great thing
so let's start with you if you can kind
of give a summary of what you think
happened last time what do you think
happened and then what do you think what
would you want the haters to know about
what happened yeah I think for me the
biggest thing that um I was not going
into it thinking of a debate you know um
Pro reached out to me about doing a
collaboration and um so there was no
winner like I wasn't trying to win or
anything like that I think there was a
lot of miscommunication and I think
there's a lot of misunderstanding I
think a lot of us talking over one
another and so I'm really hoping that
today we can be able to clarify those
things but I just feel like the previous
conversation was just one big
miscommunication on both sides gotcha so
what would you say to the haters they
were like no that's it Hafiz I thought I
liked you but no that's it like any of
those guys I mean listen if you don't
have haters you're not doing something
right so don't worry about that but what
would you say to those people who are
who are kind of talking smack about you
the reality of life is that all people
can do is
try their best to represent themselves
you know people when um the late Kevin
Samus passed away I said people aren't
who they are on their best days neither
are they who they are on their worst
days they are who they are on most days
which is a human being trying their best
and so my desire is I'm not here to
change anybody's mind
um whatever you believe you believe
about me um but I'm just here to Simply
communicate to help the most men
possible because end of the day what
matters the most in today's conversation
is men winning so that's what it's all
about I love that so did I talk over you
in that conversation
in regards to no you said we talked over
each other did I talk over you so in
regards to the conversation I'm not
going to lie to you I I haven't went
back and rewatched it but I didn't know
it's a lot of miscommunication but I
think the biggest thing is that we're
here today to be able to move forward
and that's what I really want to focus
on so my question to you is so give me
your give me your perspective what
happened what did you expect to happen
like and then what in reality what did
happen give me your expectations versus
reality yeah um I actually expected to
agree with you on most stuff um I didn't
expect it to be a debate at all either
um I just found it hard to like get a
word in to be honest
um and a lot of times I would try to
talk and I I didn't really I felt like I
couldn't talk on my own show well listen
I mean shout out to what we're doing
here this is why you have a moderator an
arbitrator and a host to make sure that
we have equal opportunity to speak so
you're going to have just as much time
as a piece to speak today so you go what
did you want to say last time that you
weren't able to say if you're saying
that he was speaking over to you what do
you think
um I would say last I was more of a
question
um
would you say so you said you don't
disagree or you disagree with the red
pills description of marriage
um I was just curious why okay so why do
I personally disagree with the virtual
and then disagree with marriage
um for anybody watching this what are
they because I can I ask one more thing
I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry yeah but
like do you think that what they're
saying about the laws is untrue no okay
no 100
um so
um for anybody watching this today I'm
gonna be trying to quote as many
statistics as possible
um my desire to represent the
information that people can do with it
whatever they want so if you guys go to
the uh roommates YouTube channel go to
the community tab there's gonna be um
statistics damage I'm a quote I want
people to criticize and scrutinize it
pick it apart because the end of the day
it's about the information that helps
men so Natalia if you don't mind can you
go to the document that I shared you um
data for men
um about marriage benefits for men so
the first thing that I've heard
communicated is that marriage has zero
benefits for men and if and if it's true
that marriage has zero benefits for men
that's true and we need to talk about
that but according to statistics and the
Harvard study there are many benefits
um
um in marriage for men for example men
have married men have lower mortality
rates men have married men have lower
depression rates lower Alzheimer's rates
um lower decreased cancer deaths if you
scroll down a little bit of tally if you
don't mind optimal home life to be able
to raise their children and married men
earn more money that's additional
statistics as well so they there are
benefits for a man today when it comes
to marriage in regards to some of the
challenges you're 100 right there are
challenges and there are issues and we
need to address them and solve them but
they are benefits for men today and I
want men to know The Good the Bad and
the Ugly when it comes to marriage and
just to be clear here because
um we're going to go through a whole
range of topics so you're going to be
doing more answering than questions but
that's fine you ask the question I think
it's important to establish you're
married correct yes sir you've been
married for how long oh over a year okay
so you're married so okay and you're
single we talked about this yesterday a
lot of DMS coming in in the inbox these
days
but we are talking about marriage right
here so
um I guess let me give you guys some
stats and we'll kind of open up for for
dialogue so marriage in Western Society
is definitely on the decline there's a
there's a quote from New York Times
saying that the married will soon be the
minority right and usually people get
married all over time it's also no
secret we talked about this yesterday uh
that men tend to be the big losers in
the court system especially when a
divorce happens in marriage Okay so
it's not an all bad thing it's not an
all good thing like there's benefits to
marriage there's prose there's cons so
are is it is it is your question saying
are you basically saying the red pill
um props up marriage or basically disses
marriage saying that there's no benefit
to it and a man should not get married
is that essentially what you're saying
about the red pill and you're
essentially saying no there are benefits
like give me your your full scope of
your argument yeah so the full scope of
the argument is that I agree uh Pearl
talked about some of the laws today and
you and I hope you get into the
statistics men need to know about the
bad the ugly and the terrible laws going
on today we need to address those so the
bad and ugly when you talk about but
there are good things about marriage and
there's a lot of Statistics that we'll
go through today about the benefits so
my biggest thing is that if the red pill
is telling the truth the truth is the
good that's happening the bad is
happening and the ugliness happening so
my biggest issue is that when we're not
communicating we're only communicating
the bad and ugly and removing the good
you're not communicating the full Truth
For Men is that what you think is that
is that I guess the perspective from the
red pill is that marriage is not a good
thing like the reason that you're asking
you start you could you add one thing to
ask him and you started with marriage I
assume that's it
okay well actually that's a major thing
you want to address so from your
perspective what is Hafiz not
recognizing have you heard Rolo say that
men and women are better together than
they are apart
because
I used to have I heard Rallo say what he
he says that men and women are better
together than they are apart okay um I
think a lot of guys believe in the
institution of marriage just not the
legal side of it
yeah so that's okay like I just don't
think that's true I think they say
there's no benefits like in like legally
not
not not like as an institution so
unpacked that a little bit so I'm saying
like
men and women are better together
marriage is a good thing but the way
it's set up today just doesn't benefit
men yeah not I mean we talked about it
yesterday 90 of men don't get custody of
their kids in a divorce right we talked
about that yesterday these are just
stats not my opinion uh women initiate
70 of divorces that goes up to 90 if
they're college educated
um women get the kids 90 of the time uh
they they was at 90 of the time they're
getting the ones getting alimony I don't
have those exact stats we talked about
yesterday but with anything there's risk
and reward with anything I what I don't
care if it's driving a car I don't care
if it's getting married I don't care if
it's going swimming if it's working out
if it's going out partying and drinking
there's risk and reward so
you're basically saying hey cool I got
married Bro yeah like there's a major
reward to it I recognize the risk but
obviously the reward outweighs the risk
and my question to you Pearl is do you
personally Pearl
um believe that there is any benefits
for men to get married today
legally no in general
together I mean my parents are married
I'm really thankful for having two
parents in the home I just think
from a legal perspective like if I was a
guy I probably wouldn't get married
legally so you're saying that there is
benefits that that men have to be
married today
from a not from a legal yes so not from
illegal there is benefits can you name a
few of them if you don't mind
okay I liked having two parents in the
home I think that's good I think
commitment is good
um
and how does that benefit men so I'm
just I want to be specific with you so
you said men did not legally of course
but there are benefits for men today
when it comes to marriage
yes they picked the right girl I think
um having a support system is good but
that's also dependent on if they pick
the right of course 100
um I think that having someone
I don't know I just think it's better to
like have someone by your side of course
yeah I love it I love it and one of the
things and I really appreciate you
sharing that Pearl is I want to clarify
something that may be I may not have
communicated properly
there are certain things I stand for I
want to see men have money in their
pockets a family by their side and
respect on the name I've been been
talking about that theme and I believe
those are good things for men anything
that I see trying to take that away from
men so any bad idea that's what I'm
against so I'm not against any
individual person I'm against any idea
that I personally believe hurts the
lives a mess I want to clarify as we
continue to move forward I'm never
against any individual person I want to
see every single man have the best life
possible one of the things I loved about
Pearl before the show started she was
talking about her dad her dad's like a
freaking rock star that compliments the
encouragement like just her as a woman
like like by having an amazing father
really benefit her life I want to see
more women have fathers like Pearl I
want to see more men become fathers like
her father was and so any idea that
helps men I love it any idea I think
that hurts man I'm against it 10 kids in
the and that's crazy and which one are
you by the way oh gosh it depends you
count it I grew up with six I was the
second to six and then they adopted
three teenagers later and then I
actually had a brother at 22 they gave
up for adoption when my mom was 17. so I
didn't find out find out about him until
I was older but out of the original six
I grew up with I was second okay you're
the second oldest second youngest second
oldest oh wow well well third if you
count the brothers yeah that's what I
say it is crazy
Beyond ridiculous ten kids uh respect to
to I don't even know your last name and
someone asked me he goes Adam what's
Pearl's last name I go I think it's
things
what is your last name yeah Davis Pearl
Davis there it is the name you know
um we just established two things that
two things can be true at once that
there's a lot of benefits to being
married to raising your kids in a single
family household and and being together
but hey you should also recognize that
there's a lot of risks involved in
marriage especially being a dude is this
fair to say a hundred percent I mean is
there anything like would you want to
push back on that either one of you
look at us look at us Adam I have a
question for you so I love that
statement I love how Pearl agreed to it
you're a guy who's very
um intuitive of guys as many of you know
I was just banned on Tick Tock and we
are demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible